during a recession people go towards
security and so what happens is Brands
become more important during a downturn
it's the time where people are willing
to spend more to go back to the things
that they know will work and that's
where like Coca-Cola classic becomes
where everyone will funnel their money
rather than just like the new disruptive
innovator they're like I don't know if
I'm gonna spend money on this side thing
now because money's not flowing so I'd
rather pay down my Risk by going with
the sure thing or the known thing the
messaging of Brands goes from thriving
to surviving it goes towards security
instead of like missing out it's about
like future proofing and protecting and
securing your future but the ones that
will do the best during those times are
the ones who spent the time before the
recession building their brand building
Goodwill building trust so that during
this time period they can glob up more
market share